en el vídeo pasado empezamos a ver las
ideas básicas de una función de consumo
y vimos que no era muy sencillita verdad
simplemente es una función que describe
como el ingreso agregado lleva a consumo
agregado en una economía empezamos con
un modelo super simple verdad que era
una función de consumo lineal estaba muy
facilita tenía un nivel base de consumo
que no dependía del ingreso agregado y
luego teníamos un cierto consumo
adicional causado por un cierto ingreso
disponible y entonces al graficar lo se
veía algo así verdad era una línea que
iba de este punto a este de acá y te
dije que esto de aquí pues no tiene que
ser la única forma en la cual podemos
construir una función de consumo
podríamos usar un poco de matemáticas
más sofisticadas y construir una función
de consumo algo así verdad donde la
propensión marginal al consumo es alta
cuando hay un bajo nivel de ingresos y
va disminuyendo y disminuyendo conforme
el nivel de ingresos va aumentando
entonces pues si a lo mejor tiene
justificación que el modelo sea más
sofisticado y que su gráfica quede más
coqueta así como la dibuje y entonces si
tendremos que usar algo más complicado
que un modelo lineal
pero bueno lo que voy a hacer en este
vídeo es seguir enfocándome en un modelo
lineal y te preguntarás porque la razón
buena realidad hay dos razones número
uno es porque es muy sencillo y es muy
fácil de manipular pero número dos es
porque es el modelo que se utiliza al
principio de las clases de economía para
empezar a asimilar esta idea de las
funciones de consumo y a partir de ello
construir ideas más complicadas que
veremos en siguientes vídeos como la
cruz que inicial bueno no me quiero ir
muy adelante ahorita lo que voy a hacer
es número uno generalizar esta función
de consumo lineal y número dos la voy a
poner no solo en función del ingreso
disponible agregado que es lo que
hicimos en el vídeo pasado sino que la
voy a poner en función del ingreso bueno
del ingreso agregado de la economía
después vamos a graficar eso de allí
basado en las variables pero
especialmente va a ser lo mismo nada más
que en vez de poner numeritos vamos a
usar otras constantes entonces vamos a
poner una función de consumo lineal
vamos a poner que el consumo agregado es
igual a y entonces pues otra vez hay un
nivel base de consumo verdad aunque no
tengamos ingreso agregado necesitamos
sobrevivir necesitamos comida sobre la
mesa para lo mejor tengamos que gastar
los ahorros pero vamos a ponerle que ese
cero
s minúscula 0 esto de aquí es el nivel
base de consumo es lo que vamos a gastar
así de entrada vale el nivel de consumo
base que también se le conoce como el
consumo autónomo
consumo autónomo se le conoce como
consumo autónomo porque la gente lo
tiene que hacer lo tiene que gastar por
su cuenta aunque no tenga un consumo
adicional y luego ahora sí vamos a tener
la otra parte que si se debe a tener un
poquito más de ingreso agregado a eso le
vamos a llamar consumo inducido porque
pues podemos pensar que está inducido
por tener un poco de ingreso agregado
entonces más allá del nivel base la
gente va a gastar algo más y entonces
van a gastar no todos sino una fracción
entonces vamos a ponerle aquí ingreso
disponible ingreso
disponible disponible y bueno no otra
vez te decía no van a gastar todo si no
pueden ahorrar un poquito entonces van a
gastar una fracción que esencialmente su
propensión marginal al consumo y deja lo
pongo con otro color en naranja c1 esto
de aquí va a ser la propensión marginal
al consumo muy bien espero que esto
tenga más o menos sentido verdad mira si
aquí tuviéramos 100 de consumo base así
tendremos que comprar 100 pues no sé
miles de millones o lo que sea y luego
la propensión marginal al consumo es no
sé digamos un tercio y el ingreso
disponible o sea después del ingreso del
consumo base de ingresos disponibles de
900 entonces esto va a decir que van a
consumir un tercio de eso que obtuvieron
vale entonces si les das 900 pesos
adicionales como su propensión marginal
al consumo es de un tercio entonces en
total van a consumir 300 de esos 900
deja mejor escribo verdad para que quede
todo mucho más claro
entonces podríamos tener una situación
en la que se 0 fuera igual a 100 y luego
no se digamos que el ingreso disponible
ingreso disponible
es igual a 900
y luego se uno la propensión marginal al
consumo es un tercio o punto 3333
periódico como quieras escribirlo
entonces tiene sentido verdad las
personas van a gastar 100 pero luego
tienen 900 adicional como tienen 900 de
ingreso disponible y una propensión
marginal al consumo de un tercio
entonces su consumo va a ser igual en
este caso verdad para esta situación su
consumo va a ser de 100 más
un tercio de lo que recibieron adicional
900 entonces las cuentitas serían a ver
el consumo sería el consumo inducido
sería un tercio de 900 que sería 300 kva
entonces 300 de miles de millones de
pesos o lo que sea y además el consumo
autónomo es de 100 entonces tendríamos
400 en total muy bien entonces una vez
más esto es autónomo y esto es inducido
autónomo y en aquí no le puse y éste de
acá es consumo inducido
sumo inducido ok ahora pues ya lo puse
aquí en términos generales verdad ya
puse algunas constantes de poner
numeritos esa es la primera cosa que
dije que iba a ser verdad es lo que lo
que lo que dije que haría en primer
lugar pero también dije que expresaría
el consumo no sólo en función del
ingreso disponible sino como del ingreso
total en ingreso agregado vale y la
relación es muy sencilla la relación
entre el ingreso disponible agregado e
ingreso total ingreso agregado la
teníamos acá arriba aquí teníamos
ingreso pero en casi todas las economías
el gobierno toma un poco de peso en
impuestos y lo que queda es el ingreso
disponible entonces está muy fácil
verdad nada más como recordatorio
ingreso verdad o el ingreso agregado
pues es lo mismo que gastos agregados
que es lo mismo que producción agregada
y entonces el ingreso lo podemos pensar
como el producto interno bruto deja le
pongo la ye mayúscula que identifica el
producto interno bruto entonces el
ingreso disponible es de menos el
ingreso agregado menos los impuestos
entonces deja le pongo menos t
con otro color menos impuestos después
no queremos confundir la iv de impuestos
con la inversión entonces lo pongo de
tax entonces podemos expresar el ingreso
disponible como el ingreso agregado
menos los impuestos menos impuestos para
entonces podemos reescribir todo esto
para que quede más limpio el consumo
agregado es igual a el consumo autónomo
más la propensión marginal al consumo se
1 x y entonces le ponemos ingreso
agregado que es lo mismo que el producto
interno bruto menos impuestos puestos
hasta entonces ya no logramos
generalizar nuestra función de consumo y
número 2 no pusimos en función del
ingreso agregado en vez del ingreso
disponible muy bien para dejarte
tranquilo de que esto sigue siendo una
línea cuando en vez de graficar lo en
términos de ingreso disponible lo
grafica moss un ingreso agregado déjame
manipular esta expresión un poquito
entonces vamos a distribuir este ese 1
baja que es la propensión marginal al
consumo entonces obtenemos que el
consumo agregado es igual
hace 0 el consumo autónomo y vamos a
distribuir más c 1 x este por este
entonces c 1 x por el producto interno
bruto el ingreso agregado y luego es
menos este por éste la propensión
marginal al consumo multiplicado por los
impuestos por impuestos ok y bueno como
queremos esto en función de de ingreso
agregado todo lo demás lo vamos a ver
como una constante vamos a suponer que
no cambia que son variables constantes
si quieres pensarlo así entonces vamos a
escribirlo en una forma en la cual estás
acostumbrado en la forma de la línea de
iguala a mx más ve la forma típica pues
donde aquí la equis es la variable
independiente y es la variable
dependiente y entonces y graficar amos
verdad aquí tenemos x el eje x voy a
poner acá el eje x acá tenemos el eje y
aquí que tenemos pues estoy acá
tendríamos una ordenada al origen una
intersección en el eje debe
y luego una línea que tiene dependiente
m va entonces si tenemos el cambio
llegue dividido entre entre el cambio en
x eso de ahí nos quedaría
la pendiente pendiente que es m ok
entonces esa misma situación la tenemos
aquí entonces podemos escribir esto de
esa forma donde la variable dependiente
ya no ye sino que ese es consumo
agregado y la variable independiente no
es x sino que es ingreso agregado
entonces vamos a escribirlo en esta
forma entonces vamos a escribirlo como
la variable dependiente ce que vamos a
poner en el eje y en el eje vertical va
a ser igual a la propensión imaginaria
el consumo por el ingreso agregado deja
pongo está demorada ahí está más el
consumo autónomo más el consumo autónomo
menos la profesión imaginar al consumo
por impuestos entonces es menos la
propensión marginal al consumo por
impuestos se ve muy complicado pero sólo
tenemos que darnos cuenta que esta parte
de acá es constante para que todo se vea
más sencillo constante y de esta forma
es análogo a esta cosa de acá verdad a
la vez de a la constante de la forma
tradicional de mx más
vamos a graficar si el ingreso agregado
es 0 esta expresión de 0 y el consumo
sería esta expresión de acá
de hecho déjame graficar lo
una vez más ahí tenemos una gráfica
nuestra variable dependiente sería ce el
consumo agregado y nuestra variable
independiente en este caso ya no va a
hacer ya no va a ser ingreso disponible
sino que ahora va a ser ingreso agregado
va en mayúscula ok entonces si no hay
ingreso agregado verdad es la variable
independiente si no hay ingreso agregado
entonces el consumo nada más va a ser
este valor entonces el consumo sería
este valor de acá verdad que sería 0 - 0
1 x los impuestos por t y luego conforme
tienes un ingreso agregado mayor y mayor
entonces se uno pues sea uno sería como
la pendiente entonces es que tanto se
contribuye al consumo inducido déjame
poner esto de esta forma lo voy a poner
así no quiero confundirte mucho nada más
quiero hacer la analogía de que es igual
a mx más b va aún más bien debería
escribirlo
de esta forma verdad se es igual a
m así en rojito no quiero otra vez no
quiero confundirte con la mlb ahorita
nada más es para hacer la analogía sale
entonces es para que éste no nos basemos
en las ideas de álgebra que ya teníamos
entonces es igual a m más vea entonces m
sería la pendiente b sería la ordenada
al origen la intersección en el eje c
entonces b es este numerito de acá y es
donde se intersecta y luego éste es la
pendiente que sería c 1 que es la
propensión marginal al consumo entonces
nuestra línea se vería algo de este
estilo donde la pendiente es igual a la
propensión marginal al consumo que es
igual a c 1 y bueno no sé si de repente
las personas están dispuestas a gastar
más de su impuestos más de su ingreso
entonces la propensión marginal al
consumo aumentaría la pendiente
aumentaría en la línea sería así
y por ejemplo como la propensión
marginal al consumo siempre es menor que
1 la línea nunca tiene más de 45 grados
y como no es negativa entonces la línea
no puede tener una pendiente negativa
pero por ejemplo la gente puede decidir
ahorrar más no sé porque son tiempos
difíciles y entonces la línea se vería
menos pronunciada